yeah welcome a new game and I'm play
Knight f3 I need to check who this guy's
tie here whack it off from speaking
stone former USSR rapid champion yeah
there are more grandmasters under the
funding you can't imagine okay I'll play
the the so-called double fianchetto here
and we even got how would you call this
quadruple fianchetto so on complete down
okay not complete symmetry I was
expecting c5 d5 surprisingly okay
exchanging c4d porn and some usually am
a desirable thing to do and now while
just before y'all need to grab some
space in the center okay p.m. it seems
he's some trying to prepare c5
understandably how do how to react to
that interesting dumb so I feel I should
I should have something here but this
doesn't feel right to me mess set up if
while a 496 is not probably not very
promising
I want to play on see if I want to play
efore at d5 if possible this would be
quite quite nice okay come on em if I
spend too much time it doesn't really
help the idea is to cover I to clear d14
rook and play Queen B to at some point
with the check after c5 is played the
only thing is I could have played this
move of course after 10 seconds it not
after after you know 60 seconds or
whatever I spend came so preventing c5
and i will now this and on c5 i have g5
this looks like a very promising
position now c 55 and and black really
isn't in trouble he maybe wants to go
nitey form hmm see if i can see what i
can also just maybe just take so okay
let's let's prepare this 94 so also
losing quite some time maybe even I'd be
five for checking oops attacking a seven
try to use this this diagonal with this
pin so at some point I move like I move
like Nigeria stop back he played c6 and
block the diagonal don't do my dad 97 no
threatened and he cannot play c5
yeah this is excellent now just um just
got we go the week c67 pond question is
some what is the optimum to to exploit
that taking is also an option of course
are too hard to say the the maximum of
this position b5 where do you go
probably know where we should be 70
Scott down 95 so some a track to take
off so we're just 93 now or something or
where what's the best square let's let's
drop back
probably this roof I've got I've got
ideas of rookie and time Quincy three
yeah it's some still slightly tricky
with little time
yeah I mean this is relatively easy if
you would play am a long time control
game but it's not so easy to to keep
keep everything together here with them
it's got a well-positioned light and an
active rook on the second-ranked okay
need to play quickly turn sometimes you
rather instantly see that you made at
least a risky move
check check check check time warning
yeah just 19 seconds and he's just
trying to do something on my time cause
I mean from a pure move kind of
perspective this game also just just
terrible fine he just played very very
badly i mean for Grandmaster this was
really bad okay luzon time now but it's
not so easy to do the technical job with
with a bit of a bit of a time down I
probably should have killed him
somewhere here I mean this is just just
a peace forum for not much but um
probably probably there's some some
quicker way net term at some point yeah
this is a bit annoying with the night
coming to c5 and his position is rather
compact so it's um I mean okay what I
did simply its winning ads not not the
problem but 30 seconds is the problem um
just need some some precision at some
point
and then you you you just win yeah this
is also just winning I mean you try to
find the thing okay where did I go wrong
but basically I didn't do much wrong
here it's just them it just slow I think
I'm quite interesting was this this is
some this part and now I think black is
already in some trouble I mean he will
never get get some decent play in the
center down frankly speaking this D 5s
is just nonsense I mean d 596 you cannot
play in this way and what I just got a
big a big edge here the night on a six
is just a terrible piece yeah c6 I mean
and now Black is just passive but I mean
you need to to try to get some activity
going maybe see five or something and
this is just this is just over I mean
okay just too slow yeah thanks for
watching